les doy la bienvenida a la entrevista en
ram24 hoy con el premio Nobel de
literatura 2021 adultorada gorna
adul raza gorna Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en 24
después de diez libros y una carrera
completa como profesor de literatura
inglesa y poscolonial
su vida cambió cuando el 7 de octubre de
2021 en la cocina de su casa recibió una
llamada diciéndole que era el ganador
del premio Nobel
after obviamente hay un antes y un
después en términos de reconocimiento de
cobertura de prensa pero también algo
más concreto en términos de traducción y
difusión de su obra este libro La vida
después es un ejemplo
se publicó en inglés en 2020 pero esta
versión en español acaba de salir
era paradójico para ustedes escribir
sobre la migración sobre personajes que
están entre países e idiomas mientras
sus libros no podían viajar tan lejos ni
ser traducidos lo suficiente
sí es cierto que la concesión del Nobel
supuso una gran diferencia para que los
libros volvieran no solo el más reciente
sino también los demás
pero en el idioma original en inglés
algunos de ellos ya estaban
descatalogados los libros no se imprimen
durante mucho tiempo a menos que ocurra
algo como un premio Nobel pero también
en nuevos idiomas en los que no había
sido traducido nada mío Antes
había traducciones No es que no las
hubiera pero no como ahora ahora hay
muchas traducciones que es lo más
maravilloso del premio Nobel porque es
algo global todo el mundo lo conoce y
quiere saber quién es ese abdulzac y
cómo es su obra
y quieren hacerlo con su propio idioma
Aunque sepan leer en inglés y me parece
estupendo es algo brillante que le
ocurra a un escritor
la vida después sigue la historia a
principios del siglo XX de tres
individuos ordinarios atrapados entre
conflictos mucho más grandes que ellos
primero vale mañana y Gran Bretaña
luchando para África Oriental y luego la
Primera Guerra Mundial pero no se trata
de contar lo que les ocurre durante Esos
grandes acontecimientos históricos se
trata de las secuelas y demostrar Cómo
siguen con sus vidas mostrando el trauma
y las consecuencias en los detalles más
pequeños porque esta elección
tratar de entender algo como ese
episodio de La historia
pero tratando de entenderlo no de la
manera como ácido narrada por personas
que vienen a luchar una extensión de sus
Guerras en Europa
Así que para la gente que vivía en
aquellos lugares era una guerra
incomprensible que no tenía nada que ver
con ellos es en cierto modo una especie
de etapa tardía de la lucha por África
quien va a tener Qué territorio
Así que quería esa perspectiva de gente
viviendo sus vidas y sus vidas
sobrepasadas por estos enormes
conflictos que les involucran
independientemente pero que en cierto
modo no tiene nada que ver con ellos
aunque sean partícipes
así que hay una ironía en el hecho de
que la mayoría de los combatientes en
ese episodio entre 1914 y 1918 sean en
realidad africanos luchando por este
bando o luchando por aquel bando
mercenarios de ejércitos coloniales y
hay ironía en eso por qué lo hizo esa
gente porque no pensó o gane quien
pierda nos van a colonizar no vamos a
ser libres como resultado de participar
en una guerra así pero la gente lo hizo
y murió por esas causas que no
significaban nada para ellos pero
también hay gente corriente que sigue
con sus asuntos que significa Quiénes
son estas personas y por qué luchan
quien quería esa sensación de que la
gente continúa creo que como seres
humanos tenemos esa capacidad
continuando con sus vidas independientes
de estos grandes incomprensibles quizá
incluso inútiles conflictos que están
teniendo lugar
usted habla siempre de la resiliencia de
sus personajes
Buenos días en efecto Esta es una de las
preocupaciones interesantes para mí como
escritor no solo en este libro sino en
muchos otros
es la forma en que la gente recupera
algo del trauma Esta es la frase que
utilizo
porque recuperar no es necesariamente
volver a lo que había antes recuperar
algo humano algo que te permite pasar a
la etapa siguiente
o incluso reanudar una vida de
generosidad y ordinaries
hace unos meses con la muerte de la
reina Isabel la historia de su vida y de
su reinado estaba en todas partes y la
historia de su legado colonial Cómo se
sintió al ver y de pronto al participar
en esta conversación
Bueno tengo que decir que ninguna de las
cosas que se dijeron a raíz de la muerte
de la reina era nuevas para mí
Aparentemente fue noticia para mucha
gente y eso solo puede ser algo bueno
para intentar situar Su comprensión
quiero decir en la sociedad británica Su
comprensión del imperio en el momento
presente pero también en la historia
Así que creo que fue una conversación
útil yo no participé en ella pero pude
ver de pie al margen mirando que era
algo que estaba teniendo efecto hacía
que la gente viera las cosas no todo el
mundo pero hacía que la gente viera las
cosas de una manera un poco diferente
sobre ese periodo y sobre el papel que
el gobierno la monarquía etcétera
jugaron y siguen jugando
usted escribe sobre la complejidad de la
identidad hay un escritor Franco libanés
animalus no sé si lo conoce yo sí no le
conozco pero conozco su obra
él también escribió mucho sobre la
complejidad de la identidad y dice que
cada identidad es muy singular
porque nadie en la Tierra tiene la misma
combinación de pertinencias que te hace
ser quién eres ni siquiera tu padre o tu
hija
pero escribió que la identidad es como
un dibujo en una piel tensa Deja que se
toca Una pertinencia y toda la persona
vibra qué opina al respecto
es una forma muy interesante y perspicaz
de pensar sobre el individuo
Pero podemos tener una identidad
individual en el sentido que él describe
y puedo ver que sí todo el mundo es
único en ese sentido concreto pero
también podemos tener una identidad más
general de personas que comparten
ciertos momentos momentos históricos
podríamos decir o que comparten
experiencias de cierto tipo y hay grados
en los que podemos decir aquí nuestras
identidades se solapan en cierto modo Y
tenemos algo en común y esto no tiene
que ser étnico o incluso nacional ni
nada por el estilo
Y creo que este es el modo o el motivo
por el que la literatura funciona en
diferentes culturas así yo como joven de
zanzíbar podía leer Ana karenina
y sin entender del todo lo que allí
sucedía encontrar algunos puntos de
contacto de comprensión
Esa es la belleza de la literatura creo
que nos cuenta cosas que conocemos y por
eso decimos Oh sí Y nos cuenta cosas que
no conocemos nos trae noticias nos
tranquiliza al saber que pensamos en la
misma línea que los demás yo también
pienso en eso como identidad
[Música]
a propósito de dónde le viene el deseo
de escribir en su conferencia del premio
Nobel
usted explicó que siempre le había
gustado leer y escribir durante su
infancia en sanscibar pero que cuando
huyó al Reino Unido En 1968 Todo cambió
y citó fue allí y añoranza del hogar y
en medio de la angustia de una vida
ajena donde empecé a reflexionar sobre
tantas cosas que antes no había
considerado cuénteme más
bueno eso es un resumen lo que dice
realmente es que Especialmente cuando
eres joven Cuando yo era joven y estoy
seguro de que es cierto para los jóvenes
que hacen el mismo tipo de cosas
viviendo sus hogares especialmente de
nuevo si están viviendo sus hogares de
manera difícil o en tiempos difíciles
están pensando a dónde van como yo cómo
llegar allí Cómo llegar de forma segura
Cómo negociar en este lugar extraño
y para mí fue solo después de hacer eso
que empecé a pensar
Pero qué he hecho que he dejado atrás
he hecho lo correcto
Y esa incertidumbre de dónde estaba
y comprender que quizá no era un huésped
tan bienvenido después de todo
y que he dejado allí A eso me refiero
y era joven no tenía ninguna habilidad
no tenía dinero etcétera
y en un lugar extraño así que fue a
partir de esa experiencia de alienación
Supongo pero no alienación hasta el
punto de querer hacer algo drástico si
no solo tratar de reflexionar y entender
lo que estaba pasando tratando de
parecer tan normal como cualquier otra
persona
y por último quería preguntarle ya que
estamos en el high festival de Cartagena
en Colombia si se siente vinculado a
este continente porque colonialismo la
migración el exilio los conflictos son
temas que muchos de sus lectores
actuales o futuros de aquí comparten con
usted y con sus novelas quizá más que
los lectores occidentales
sí es un gran placer estar aquí
no he estado en América Latina aunque he
leído y conozco algo de la experiencia
tanto contemporánea Hasta cierto punto
pero también la experiencia histórica
del colonialismo y la esclavitud Así que
es un verdadero placer que estos libros
puedan ser leídos por gente de aquí y
que hayan sido recibidos con cierta
generosidad
Pero por otro lado Además de eso hace un
momento me refería a que la literatura
no tiene por qué estar directamente
relacionada con tu experiencia
así que en cierto modo también otros
lugares que no tienen la experiencia
exacta de colonialismo que nosotros en
partes de África y en América Latina
compartimos es decir colonialismo
europeo de cierto tipo invasión
conquista etcétera Pero aún así pueden
ver algo en estos libros Así que está
bien es bueno
Muchas gracias y gracias a ustedes por
su confianza pueden seguirnos en las 24
y tras 24.com